women is like our first response is to
blame somebody else and not ourselves um
but I also wanted to point out that
women are very influenced by the culture
women are very influenced by their
friends women are very influenced by
their family women are influenced by
everybody around them and that is what I
see a lot of like tradcons I guess
they'll basically act like their women
are inept to the culture and it can
never happen to them and then time and
time again we see that it does for
example Dennis Prager has been married
three times many public media
Conservative Christian personalities
have been married multiple times for
example Tom Brady you know and you ask
yourself were those men not alha enough
were they not did they not lead well
enough and that's why I point out that
men have a very real reason to fear
marriage I think it's a valid concern
and for some men it's just not going to
make sense